place I'm gonna wait a second before I
go the only ones that use are Zeki
stream health that's good all right
receiving content all right and we are
live welcome to the iron Lords podcast
and the Lords of gaming dotnet episode
number 127 and it's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the roundtable on
the Lord's Day I'm very excited about
our special guests and we've got so many
state of play Last of Us 2 multiplayer
inside Xbox and Project X cloud beta to
discuss so we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce a lord who the ILP
recently had the privilege of meeting in
the flesh at play NYC 2019 now I did
this law provide opportunity for the
dreams of our game developers to become
a reality
but it's an absolute trailblazer for
game conventions with a New York state
of mind introducing the founder and CEO
of play crafting producer of the bid
Awards and the play NYC gaming
convention one of the most passionate
gaming executives in the game and the
official Young Buck when it comes to
human algorithms laughs from the new
mecca of gaming New York City is making
his debut into the realm of the Lord's
my man Lord and Butch go how you doing
sir hey happy Sunday happy Sunday we
made it we made it a pleasure to have
you in the room you are Lord at what you
do so it's only right we show you the
proper respect to you at the round table
how's it going man it's been good it's
uh it's I can't believe it's been a
month and a half since playing YC and
we're already ramping up for the next
moment that's pretty nuts I know we're
talking of live a you're ready
you got the wheels turned everything
ready to go there
good I've used the the chance in the
past month to also like catch up on a
bunch of games that I've been wanting to
play so that's also been nice to have a
little bit of down time I saw you an
extra trade yeah and I'll show you a
switch play it as your dad's like that's
a lot of play Ashville chain is like my
number one contender for unity
say it would you just do that I get a
lot of opposition in here from game of
the year so far by far I'm going between
four games on switch I've got a
Asheville chain Dragon Quest builders to
untitled goose game which lasts
incredible but they turn it into like an
MCU style Universal dog game and I mean
because I just want more and more of it
yes you can do with that goose to harass
people is absolutely worth one is of the
remake of Link's Awakening yes King he's
been trying to sell plain as a goose for
like three weeks now let me tell you
something person has stood up for this
game man talk to himself the a whole
goose game you know it's like it's what
it you know get you that cool because
y'all all have the same little grin we
need King to start reviewing games on
early shout out to my man dizzy okay
busy I gotta give you a few super Josh
in a second um we want nice fantastics
for the $2 super check thank you dizzy
you want me to start doing reviews I
want you to start reviewing your camera
[Laughter]
- dizzy with the $2 super chat bag
coming in and this is live from the ER
and you know first of all I give him a
special shout-out cuz our brother
brother he's sort of serious no easel
he's battling cancer right now and he is
literally live from the ER doing this I
mean from the hospital doing this and um
I just want to say brother we miss you
you know all the lords have offs we have
your support you know I'm saying I know
he's hurting right now cuz I believe
shadow keep drops this week you do what
you wanted to play but that's our editor
Lord and chief of Lords of gaming died
how did you believe shadow key please
send them your love the messages keep
his spirits up like I said he starts his
chemo this week and we are rocking with
him and to see him in here doing his
normal jokes antagonizing king he was on
my head on Twitter and I just wanted to
give him a special shout-out because
brother your spirit is strong and I'm
with you and yes listen when the
PlayStation file come out we swipe we're
fine anyway salute Lord dizzy thereby
brother man we hold the fort down till
you get back so anyway and you know we
already have the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original laws of the room at the
round table
my co-host with the co-host my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror Lord of reviews and the hop of
the young wolf mommy Lord addict are you
doing sir I'm pretty good question do
you have like our individual intros like
saved and you just copy and paste that
will you write the show every week but
majority of them are off memory I'm
gonna tell you that's off the top I just
like to add little spices and stuff
based on current events and I was gonna
tell you you're saying husband I feel I
ain't wrong you saying it wrong
he the hard gamer you know and I gotta
tell you this this man is a video game
savant and we're not gonna underscore
the fact that he goes out there and
plays these games on the Hard difficulty
level for god knows why these
coordinator shooters now I'm not making
everything into into a bullet sponge and
they call that a heart anyway what have
you been playing sir uh Final Fantasy 8
I finally put that on the switch and
I've been playing a lot of destiny here
lately actually oh I love rocky sadly on
the Xbox I know she rested people now
rest in peace only the PC will be back
up and running so you be good I felt
what happened here to get again yes yeah
the USB you see we're gonna get it - we
got a lot of time of course we have our
most technical gaming Lord the solo game
of the list for the single-player
selfish experience and also not soft
Adamas mister I was about two dollars
the profile Illuminati and Lord patreon
of the iron bank mommy
Lord sovereign are you doing sir well
good morning good morning good morning I
have been playing just Link's Awakening
man I haven't been home I haven't I was
hoping to place of Gears last night that
didn't happen cuz that boxing had me
open last night I was first time in a
long time I'm paying attention to a
fight without doing something else yeah
so I was paying attention ass or no gear
so hopefully I'll play some gears today
but just plain Link's Awakening out
yesterday got to hang out with my nephew
took him to see abominable and how is it
that's beautiful little movie he loved
it very nice movie kind of formulaic but
whatever it was good
they're trying to compare it to them how
to fly dragon and you know I'm gonna
take my kids to see but if it's a blue
way I could wait off just let me know
it's it's nice - it's not a it's a story
you've seen before I don't think it
compares a
train your dragon' that okay that's kind
of epic that that that whole trilogy of
movies is pretty good and then I we
played some mega Sega Genesis mini man
he doesn't he doesn't have the only the
only attachment he has to Sega is Sonic
but beyond that so I too want Streets of
Rage it was open I was so happy to see
him come on deal let's beat these guys
liquid character would carry DP oh he
played in place so yeah it was a fun
time again and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS gamer
ooh the Lord of combat sports king of
the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement it
came up
love it like a guy you doing sir oh my
god you guys know exactly how we do Oh
baby
all right listen we're gonna get this
real quick real quick and and Dan really
doesn't have all the time in the world
so listen the Staples Center was rocking
yesterday the Staples Center has two
champions going up to the ring this is
uh this was disrespect forces respect
all right and you have to understand one
person was going there to disrespect
somebody another person was going at his
snatch respect and I think both things
got accomplished last night you had
Shawn Porter versus old Spence jr.
Prinze jr. is the heir apparent the
Floyd Mayweather if you didn't know
alright this is what they're calling him
they call him the baddest man on the
planet the boogey man a dude and I
rigged the Jabba Binks but this is what
happened he learned last night the honey
badger was not afraid of anything
the honey badger stood in his chest and
hit him with everything that didn't have
a glove on it hit him with the knees
elbows head and chest he hit him with
his back everywhere everybody man said
and I quote he's going to fill me in the
rain his horse he said that and I'm
gonna tell you this he felt him pause he
if you saw what Earl Spencer jr. look
like after the
right you got touched up
he learned I thought it was a calculated
area the Sean Porter's father told him
give him the body and we'll take his
head I think I think that was a bad
judgment in corner because Earl Spence
lives in the body now what I saw was
fighted here yes what I saw was two
combatants that will not allow they
wills to be your whistle ooh it was to
listen when else was Junior knock now
show Porter in eleventh round he said
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
he looked over at him and said not
tonight you're not getting this body
tonight tonight
you gonna earn everything you get yeah
and it was fitting that it went to a
split decision you know I didn't agree
with it going to a split decision and I
felt that Earl's burns did enough to win
in a unanimous two unanimous decision
but I say this I said as a champion
who's been fighting 15 years and this is
his first pay-per-view you saw a man
change yes he went from being the b-side
always being overlooked always being
talked down always being abused verbally
always to being a one sharp clean he
fought with a level of ferocity from
round one to round twelve with the same
energy I said you have to eat capsulate
his blood and give it down it sounds
cheesy but it felt like a rocky moment
you know that moment when Apollo Creed
starts respecting rocky in the ring he's
like oh my god what have I got myself
into
you felt that moment last night that
right there is one of those boxer man
again I don't watch box as much as I
used to I knew I had to watch that one
and it blew beyond the billing like it
was I'm to me I think Shawn Porter earns
so much respect
Louis dad I was just like well I have to
watch all his face now I I've never
really watched him prior to that that's
how he fights but he yesterday he was at
11
yeah I'm gonna say this this is a
wake-up call for Spence yes yes you
can't get by on pure town alone buddy
you got he had to dig dent down
therefore I respect him you dug down but
it's like you said the pure talent and
just being the bigger guy Ingle work cuz
when someone else has that same heart
and determination we saw how it could go
it was a couple moments we look at
spooky what's going on this is the
problem yeah in between fights he blows
up and wait yeah Shawn Porter from the
beginning of this year knew he had to
fight early sometime this year
mm-hmm he's been in shape since January
fellas ladies and gentlemen treated his
body as a temple yeah all the way
through to fight night real quick not to
interrupt you all metallics
thank you brother with a too loud super
chat three fingers to hide is dat or no
doubt much appreciate all right it'll be
a combat talk a results show I don't
swarm but this is necessary to be done
he'll be up later on today guys of
course we have the cooperative
experience and gaming ninja himself the
shinobi lore Cognito spread never
illness in the realm of the ILP now
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need to hear so for me just
been on Gears five destiny to shadow
keep prep obviously been playing with
addict a little bit little bit with
sinister astral chain playing that
little bit and got back to Marvel
Ultimate Alliance 3 cos my knees back
baby spider so I'm happy about that in
the MCU we had to do that and then arm
playing this beta I got accepted by the
beta office again called tower of tower
of something it's a beta exponents I
thought yous about to say I got accepted
to Xbox cloud I was this park as right
now to skip ahead program and I got
accepted to console srimad so look we
got a lot to talk about
now go unlock we already know
boys have gotten into what they've been
playing but I want to start with Lord
and his videogame system history his
journey into the gaming industry to
become the CEO of play crafting and of
course what led him to be the producer
of the bit awards and the Lords favorite
game of convention play NYC so oh wow
very good what a first video gives us if
you had and what got you to gaming
my mom got me into games and the first
system we had was the original Nintendo
mmm so I fell in love with names
when my mom booted up the first Legend
of Zelda in like 1989 I was four years
old yeah the gold caught 50 yeah the
only one which would with sickness a
feat read something like a battery
inside I believe right yeah yeah yeah so
you stuck with Nintendo give me some
other titles in their system and that
you remember if you if you are so so
Zelda was the first one but the game
that we played the most as a family was
The Simpsons Bart vs. the spaceman
yeah kick definitely kick yes I'm a huge
box Simpson and Simpson fan so I
definitely digging like a solid six
years of my childhood collecting every
possible piece of Simpsons memorabilia I
was obsessed with The Simpsons three
years yeah to stick it in check where
did you go there sure so stuck with NES
for that round and then my family
switched over to Sega Oh ecosystem
sister did you pick up we got the Sega
Genesis and we went deep into Sega I had
a game gear and I loved it
beautiful yeah that's a good talk yeah I
hear to me like I did not have an
original Gameboy I don't think I had a
gameboy until like the SP and like 99 or
so and so so a Game Gear was my jam for
the longest time and so late uh
obviously all three of the first Sonics
there was an x-men game on there that
was I don't think it was a port of the
Sega game but it was a lot like it yeah
yeah there was a game called slider on
the gamegear if you've never played it
before you've got to play it you're just
playing you're playing like a he kind of
looks like a Kirby knockoff Orange Kirby
and you just like the whole purpose of
the level is you have to like move him
over every single box and so it's a
gigantic like almost like a disco floor
of like that makes any sense
he's all throughout it you just have to
like go over each block in order to
change the colour on it and I was
obsessed with that game it was called
slider slider I got it yeah like a Kirby
knockoff right that was my jam it was so
good longest son I was gonna ask you
quick quick about game because I know
sometimes like you actually the first
actually would have mentioned it really
actually I said guess to their history
so like I always wonder when I'm not
like solve you had one right yeah I had
one Nana nomadic but I heard that you
needed stock in there so basically like
you remember they had like portable TV
news to so you're literally a miniature
box so for you to show up with this
chunky here you were so cool and it was
like
evie as hell it had like a half hour
battery life or something from outlet
outlet but if it was it was the first
time you had this fully backlit all
color your green for games and so it
when I was a kid I was like I didn't
care if it was Nintendo or Sega just
like so like taking it back but I had
this glowing screen in front of me like
that yeah in color oh that's right
literally woods but so did like I said
you got Game Gear you had Genesis on so
you kind of rocked out did you kind of
just transition straight over the portal
or did you kind of we're doing both like
would you still invest it with the
Genesis ecosystem or you just where did
you go after these two yeah yeah so
after that my brother who's four years
older than me he kind of took the lead
for a couple of years in the console
decision-making and that that was the
only like two year three year period
where my family was exclusively a
playstation family oh man they make the
moves yeah family makes the decisions
with the counselors like they do the
Sega yeah and now it's okay PlayStation
is this so that's right oh I think what
she probably wound up doing was like
just agreeing with whichever son of hers
like wanted the system and the games
that she wanted please I would do the
same thing so bob is a gay bob was
hardcore yeah it's hardcore yeah Wow
yeah that's how many one older brother
one other brother so you guys so it was
playing town you guys are going at it
with it with the to play of stuff as
well I'll play it again yeah it started
out as like before we had video games
when we were super young we play this
game called toy war where we would just
set up all of our action figures against
other and then we would just change the
rules all throughout and because the
older brother he he would always change
the rules so he would win so like it
would be all action figures and then he
grab a stuffed animal and you'd say oh
yeah we can play with stuffed animals
now and then just plop on top of being
pity
yeah so PlayStation may God be through
real quick bag it'd be substantial it's
give me some things for the PlayStation
the PlayStation I didn't play it - too
much my brother his name's Josh he went
real deep into Final Fantasy 7 yeah we
got the system he went right to Final
Fantasy 7 Tomb Raider - not - Raider 1
the - there was a fighting game for Star
Wars called Star Wars masters of teras
kasi back then oh yeah horrible game but
you got a chance to use lightsabers
exactly I remember like that that was
the game I played the most I was still
like 8 years old 9 years old at that
point I played that game a ton on
playstation but playstation like other
than odd what's it called odd world
oddworld played a ton of on playstation
other than that though I didn't dive too
deep in it Goku and then it was probably
97 and that's when like my console
choice was like the one that won okay no
n64
oh you had to have Mary what you had
what drew you with 464 absolutely
ocarina of time and now that would be
that was like the new Renaissance of
games for me in my life I kind of like
took the back seat during the
PlayStation period in my family and uh
and once n64 came through I was addicted
to ocarina of time nice that's a big one
man
CIP fallout remastered minute so from
that point board gaming still kept on
did you did you touch xbox at all did
you
with yeah keep continuing on with the
other Playstations yeah yeah I am so
from that point on Nintendo was
definitely like the the center point of
my gaming universe but each time like
the the next round of systems came out I
went up getting all of them because it
was to the point then that I like I got
a job in high school like a patient from
my own so it didn't have to be a family
decision every single time yeah n64 then
I did a Gamecube OG xbox and patient two
but PlayStation 2 I got like three years
later he rebelled he was the first
system that I like decided I wanted and
I like read all about I fell in love
with it I got it on launch day to me
like Gamecube is my all-time favorite
system because it was and I like felt
like a real sense of ownership around no
I get that
no what was the game that did it for you
that that made you sit in that line and
get a day when that night release what
was the game it was Luigi's Mansion oh
yeah diet for three coming out next
month
number two oh yeah Luigi's Mansion did
it for me and I I think I got all four
of the launch titles it was that Super
Monkey Ball waverace Louise don't wave
yeah no go back and look at it you're
like okay console graphics are
photographed I'm so glad you said it cuz
the way you feel about that is how I
feel about when I'm Super Nintendo came
out with mobile seven and I saw F zero
for the first time there's there's
moments with graphical fidelity and I
felt waverace was one of those moments
as well like it really like no one did
water like that at that time yeah it was
like that was an ocean you were looking
at was that yeah absolutely this game
history while he took all day with this
guy certified every console that comes
out I have to I have to get it and I
usually prioritize Nintendo first but
I'd say that's like shoes like my
favorites it would be Nintendo then Sony
so tremendous tremendous history may as
well just get it to your background far
as the gaming industry man you know like
I know you kind of had a background like
what marking and event planning stuff
like that but then like what led you to
become like this CEO of this like
multi-state
haven for game developers like with the
playground yeah give us that whole thing
yeah so I actually I went to NYU for
college and I did not study anything
business or games related I went to
Social Work school so I got training in
social work on how to counsel folks and
work for great causes and health
marginalized folks and populations and
so throughout college I that's what I
studied I had a an internship on the
Lower East Side where I was working with
homeless population and so that's really
like the core of what I what I started
out in mmm-hmm
left college I graduated college worked
for six years at a non-profit raising
money for a really great cause child
abuse prevention and treatment oh wow I
don't know what it was while I was there
that I I started doing all their events
and so
all the money that we raised we would
basically raise like millions of dollars
per year from banks for this great cause
and could be they did all throughout the
country and we would do that through
events and so that was my like first
real events experience I had us download
like Adobe Creative Suite and started
learning how to like make graphics and I
went back to school and I learned and
some marketing stuff but it was probably
five years into that job where I was
like this is a great cause I loved what
I'm doing here but this is not like this
is not the core of what I do or like
longer yeah and I took some time and I
thought about it and I researched and I
realized that games had always been even
number one thing I was the most
passionate about in life and so while I
was there I got to a point where I could
do like eight hours of work in like a
two hour period I told my former boss is
a mentor of mine so I can say this like
without any shame was going high and I
made a list of every single game I've
ever played in my life
Wow yeah I still maintain that list so
once I updated I can send it your way
and we clear what you got I think it was
it like an Excel spreadsheet yeah I
figured rank them all and I I went to
GDC that year the Game Developers
Conference and that was the first time I
saw wow there's tons and tons of people
that are working in games it's not just
people playing games there's people
making a living contributing to the
culture a lot of different things and so
I I left that my job I started a side
graphic design company so I could just
pay the bills while I look old time work
in games and a friend of mine said why
don't you join some local groups why
don't you volunteer your time like do
whatever you can in New York to get
connected and so that year it was 2014
and I I volunteered for the games for
change festival in New York we'll just
focus on like games that make a
difference all the graphics the graphic
design go to supreme with a chair he's
calling you to realize
Gaming Captain America all you need to
cheer now yeah so we so I I went to the
games for change festival I volunteered
and then I joined a bunch of meetup
groups on meetup.com and one of them at
the time was called the games forum and
I got in there and it was at the
Microsoft Office there was like a play
test night and I walked in and there
were like 30 games from developers I
didn't know existed and that were in my
own backyard in New York and so that's
turbo for voiceover table at 42nd
thority yeah yeah I've been okay yeah
yeah yeah so I walked in there and I was
just blown away I connected to the folks
that started the meetup group mm-hmm and
then back then I just got an email from
like the the leader of the group that
said they were hiring someone to run
just the meetup group I applied for it
and I was hired to run the meetup group
and then we it just kind of took off
from there and I that's what guys kind
of like got together that the infamous
story of the bar meet up with exactly
yeah yeah okay a terrible cafe in like
shout-out to that cafe de is getting a
bit loud it's a chain but it was it was
not good but it was a good backdrop it
was a good bagger back job yeah so I
originally was was hired just to run the
meetup group but then got this really
great business model in place where we
could have an organization that could be
profitable and grow but also contribute
directly to the community and grow the
community and so 2015 we rebranded it as
play crafting started out as a full as
an AK
whole company mmm and then it just kind
of took off from there and so my
original goal was just to make sure that
I was building out everything in New
York so that play test night became an
expo more of them per year a winter
spring summer and fall 1 Wow they
started and all at the Microsoft Office
still so there's another one coming up
in October we still do three of them but
the summer one got so big that I said
we'll wait a minute there's something
here in New York needs its own real
full-scale commitment so we turned it
into play NYC and it became its own
convention and so things have sort of
like spun out from there where we said
we should do in the woods because now
the community has so many games coming
out of it so we started the bit of words
and that's been everyone's 2015 yeah
recent thing which really has sort of
catapulted things into the next level is
uh these big corporate partnerships that
we put together and they on paper they
they can sound kind of bland but in
practice they're awesome because we're
building these games initiatives for
these huge companies like the NFL today
and it's it's this really cool thing
where games are being created that would
never have been created before
developers that are from smaller studios
are getting paid for their work so we're
taking a ton of cash into the local
games industry and generating games for
players worldwide to experience that are
kind of like this mashup of smaller
studios and independent developers with
huge corporations and then all these
cool things happen all these great games
are developed as a source oh dude this
is an amazing story because obviously
the Lords we were able to visit play NYC
and we kind of saw that same structure
that you were talking about and again
just to see you know there's a smaller
developers what does it solve what shot
our guys from decoy you know say yeah
yeah yeah they wanna they were a bit of
woods right they what a bit of wood I
believe they were they were the big
winners earlier this year at the most
recent one yeah PC game of the year and
they got players choice which is an
audience bond yeah yes with swim sanity
you know we find out from from pax I
know King I actually king and solved
that was tool responsible for finding
those guys
you know they did the interview I was
just blown away with just the story of
three lifelong friends two brothers and
a lifelong friend that kind of came
together I was amazing and um yeah I
mean it were a couple of games we saw
there or saw I was enough Aria versus
and oh yeah oh man what's the one that
saw you loved it really much it was on
oh it was in the back you know what I'm
talking about it had custom combos and I
love that game yeah if I'm forgetting
these names off time I know he liked
back scratcher and I love the
partnership with Bose yes and [ __ ] with
Bose was it brought fun back to the
headsets I'm not gonna lie my videos up
you see me actually playing it you
actually get a workout for your neck and
I wanted to do the Bulls walk around the
city with with the virtual with the AR
glasses I wanna make a reality I thought
oh my god play New York had so much for
everybody the board games the car games
yes the video games it was it was like
he was going through different
communities like New York City like you
know you had like Brooklyn you had
Queens and Staten Island where nobody
else can come inside what we's in the
VIP section
I remember the to Nassau home fiction's
fear yeah that was and then the other
one was um kung fu kickball to solve man
he made me go over he's like no we got
to be high shelter PD style go to chat
we had so much fun with that
tremendous tremendous so real quick
about the partnerships because I know
you mentioned home he's kind of a big
deal he's a big names throw it out man
but one particular I don't was like the
Verizon and in the NFL sting and I just
want to talk about you know we see them
kind of pushing you know 5g gaming right
and I want to talk about that real quick
cuz obviously we see you know play
crafting on the front line with that and
um you know obviously the landscape has
changed you know game streaming is
really
picking up steam is like a almost like a
battle royale now you know saying we got
Patrick Atlas with ei we got stadia you
know I'm saying I'll see y'all project
Excel Microsoft so like you know where
do you think what do you think about
game streaming in general and like just
a current landscape I think game
streaming is like this year's VR and you
know everything every few years there's
a new technology that comes up that like
takes the world by storm it's like a
gold rush every company rushes toward it
and then after like two years to start
settling in and so I've been doing I've
been doing this now for five years and
so even in that span of time in the
beginning of that five year period it
was mobile games like mobile mobile
mobile all the time all the time and
then it was VR and then VR gave birth to
like X R which is they are are mixed
reality yeah and now I think streaming
is is the latest of be like upgrades and
like the new I won't call it a fad but
it's more of an innovation that changes
the landscape for sure yes but it's so
early
mm-hmm I think this is the period of
time where all of the companies like
jump out of the gate and they are
putting out what they think is the best
version of it right you know and then I
think in the next couple of years what
you'll see some of what they're trying
will work some other companies will not
work so what kind of settle in probably
two to three years on the like what
models and formula is work best but what
I get excited about is seeing the
implications for streaming on things
that are already great and things that
already exists and so give me an example
105 G side for example let's go yeah
yeah yeah for 5g I'll say that a you
know we worked with Verizon a year ago
to bring a bunch of indie developers
together to make ten of the world's
first 5g games they're not publicly
available but they were the first ones
made some of the first made and you
could literally filled out a whole
PC / console quality experience on PC
for PC and then just stream it directly
over to the phone zero lag and you would
see sort of like the comparison of when
they would try to do it on 4G versus
five you know and it was mind-boggling
yes it was worth while then the
developers would just like throw as many
characters on screen as they could as
many particle effects as many players at
the same time and so that gets me
excited it's the the streaming
capabilities of 5g me and knology that
you can take anywhere you know I was
gonna say do you think because you know
a lot of these you know corporations
companies have a privy to the access of
the 5g tech you know ahead of time and
they're seeing the excitement the
possibilities but you think it's one of
those things that you know we're in a
transitionary phase and they're trying
to get ahead of it and then obviously
people are throwing their hat and as far
as what format and what model will work
but do you think it's more of people see
the future with 5g and think that you
know what the latency issues shouldn't
be much much of a problem is what I'm
saying
yeah I think lien c is a very big part
of it for sure and that's to me that's
like the easy win right you know because
it's just a super strong connection but
what I think the most exciting part of
it is is what we don't know and that's
where like each time one of these new
pieces of technology emerge what you see
is it's like you're creating a new
frontier it's like the Old West if
you're playing Red Dead Redemption you
know like it's like this wild wild zone
where people don't know what's gonna
work they're trying to build things and
they're doing both like the the
build-out up in the vision for it when
they don't really know what it's gonna
take to get there you know and that's
what it's I think games as a whole so
exciting because this is that's a
constantly evolving process who knows
what it's going to be four years from
now five years from now when mmm-hmm
breathing has sort of settled down and
like found its place and
well are adopting it in different ways
and you know VR is still super exciting
so as a arts Oh is mr mm-hmm and I like
the fact that you had that on display
there when you first walk in and you had
a our reality walked here right and you
had the VR section to your left but like
a lot of other places would have only we
are here yeah throughout the whole NY
play NYC it was like VR here and then it
had a big booth in the back and they had
a great line to get on for the VR in the
back and I see I'm a VR guy so when I
saw and it's very important that people
don't think that it's just a fad because
it's not there's a lot of games being
made for it and people and you give the
space the space was beautiful like I was
they've really thought the space out it
was very well you know it was it
Metropolitan Pavilion right yeah there
was a game called a bizarre barber which
I got a chance to play it but we debuted
that game at PlaNYC last year we do
something called 4pt games where we like
fun some games to get made and debut I
see and they can either just be played
there and then not like go anywhere or
the developers can use it as like a
launching point to keep working on it
and bizarre barber got funding from
oculus they got acceptant program and
that's like to see these creators making
things for all of these technologies and
so even like laying out playing my C's
floor plan to me that's our opportunity
to make a physical space that is a
reflection of the current landscape of
games and specifically the landscape of
games in that region so in like the New
York Region so for us like we want to
show that games can be like weird and
wild like the backscratcher standard
like straight up sports games like we
had FIFA
mm yeah like that's that's the beauty of
games there's something for everyone
there and like people of all different
backgrounds are there because they're
united by how exciting and fun and
thought-provoking games are and so the
FIFA section look like a pub in London I
want to talk real quick um just about
the challenges of running a game
convention obviously you know last time
we talked on the show floor at play um I
see me and you you know we talked about
New York and we talked about you know
the evolution we see things right now
even currently with e3 right they're
going through an evolution on how
they're gonna be set up so I guess you
know we know that it's not cheap to get
publishers to come you know and we get
that from New York but anyway we
definitely mentioned like the tax breaks
could kind of levy eight that but like
what do we as gamers like look like what
do we need to do that to help raise
awareness or just to assist you on your
journey so that we can make it
comfortable for the triple-a devs or pop
you know to get to play NYC man yeah I
think um I think play NYC is sort of a
just like a marker and a like a symbol
of game New York honestly the best way
for gamers and fans to get attention
on New York is to support developers and
buy their games and follow their work
for folks that are in New York and
around New York you like support
games that are being made in your own
backyard and that does not mean like you
have to stop playing games
by doing that you are like showing that
developers and you're contributing to
their their work you're showing that
their work is valuable and people that
are showing their support financially
social media through all these different
channels and the more sort of
groundswell there's going to mean okay I
see where this is going so we got to
support our home home team two draft
picks the phone we got dizzy for being
petty
way to make mecca's coming to New York
man I know you Texas and I know you
feeling good right now
but no
man alright Texas you pipe down yeah so
we got it we got to support these local
guys bad that's basically what we say it
is get their stuff to the forefront get
their stuff to the forefront um I think
for us you know this is everything is an
incremental process when we started
playing YC in 2017 the only vision that
there was was New York needs its own
full scale all game that was the only
vision there was no real idea of like
okay what is this gonna what does that
mean was it gonna be in five years and
so when I and our and my team get
questions about like what do you see as
like playing wasting three years from
now or it's hard to think about that
because we are so focused on executing
now we have is right now and so that's
what we focus on each year each year is
like how do we make this the biggest
craziest most inclusive version of a
convention that New York's ever seen and
so um we've been really really fortunate
even through these corporate
partnerships that's that have come
through that it's here was the first
time that PlaNYC had a full-time team
behind them you know oh there's a lot of
like working endless hours and like
sacrificing a ton with like no
expectation or understanding of what the
outcomes going to be but just because
you believe in something and so it's a
combination of both supporting local
developers and games that are coming out
locally while also enticing and
encouraging publishers yes whereas fans
why have you been standing out front a
rock star do I need to go out there say
rock star will get rock star there and I
we had devolver this year so you know
and like it's all baby steps you know
it's like maybe it's like a mirror of
what one's personal journey is where
they say focus on your own lane only
compare yourself to what no
that's all we can do here all we can do
is look at the previous year and this
year completely how can we bring in more
how can we add more and so on a 10 by 10
space from devolver in 2019 could be in
2022 we're now at a point where devolver
and Microsoft Nintendo so these you have
a long game in your head the whole time
and not burn bridges along the way if
someone says no my mom Amazo a day with
the play man talk to ya look I love it I
love it this is good to hit this is
definitely exciting and like I said we
we we the Lords when we first heard
about you guys we were like look we've
got a support man this is something I
know from me you know as a kid the dream
was always he 3 that was the board I was
where I needed to go as a gamer to kind
of get you don't say my rite of passage
that yeah it was always in the back of
my mind is the biggest why don't we have
it in just to hear your journey and see
this thing develop you know the Lord's
gonna be with you every step of the way
so this is cool that it is a long-term
vision you know so we like to hear that
so I'm real quick on I definitely want
to ask you about I think forest like
just getting any industry I know when we
got much time with you but like I know
you guys helped Deb's you know I'm
saying and helping them get their vision
off the ground and that that's a
tremendous thing I just want you to talk
to the guy who's just like no experience
right he's just you know he came from
nothing little to no experience but he's
got that passion to make games like what
advice or steps do you give to someone
that's a gamer to get them on the right
track to be in the industry well first
of all if you are someone who loves
games then it puts you in a better place
to eventually make good games so
thinking about what like why games
resonate with you and like getting into
like the research side of things to see
how they got there and sort of what it
took to get there definitely is an easy
starting point but the beauty of how
accessible games development is now is
that all you need is the internet and a
laptop and you can
right now digital games you can all you
need I mean if you want to make like
analog games so like card games board
games all you need is a piece of paper
and a pen Wow you know so like the
barrier for entry is extremely extremely
low many games are made in the unity
engine or the Unreal Engine primarily
focused on video games and so there are
free versions of both of those that you
can Dieteman right away and on both
companies before their developer
communities with like free tutorials and
there's a lot of ways that you can go
ahead and like get started now without
having to pay the money to like go back
to school full-time or do all that right
away you can get started right now and
investing money and time on that level
is certainly something you can do when
we surpris yeah but it's not it does not
have to be step one and so honestly the
best way to get good at making games is
to make as many games as possible and to
check your ego at the door because like
when you're just a fan and a gamer and
you come in and you play let's say a
game that's on my mind a lot lately
which is the Last of Us to which I'm
dying to play when you play The Last of
Us - all you're seeing is the end
product you're not seeing the 5 years of
mistakes the mmm of bugs all the things
I didn't work just like the ban a douche
multiplayer 4 we ain't going just like I
said with PlaNYC
and let's call that like the game that
we just built for every developer that
was there there was an every exhibitor
that was there every player and fan that
was there there's probably six or seven
that weren't there that said no and
consider that our version of like the
like the roads that didn't work or like
glitches in the game along the way and
so like this this process is very
iterative and so that's where diving in
and trying to start is paramount and
I you know I'm a huge huge fan of
in-person community so there's a lot of
way to connect with people online
there's a forum you can talk to people
that are making games on the unity
forums the Unreal forums but to me it's
like join Meetup
like go find a free event find a cheap
event like like connect with people that
are near you because we're all in this
together and that hometown pride is
really really strong if you're a sport
you already know to you I got a support
the town we walked out in a sense of
pride that we have to go eat pizza we
had to recharge our batteries to come
back and the sense of pride and this is
happening and developing in New York
City what's so amazing because yeah
people you know we was walking on a
block they're like we're coming from
them we'll come from playing my seeing
you need to go there and check it out
and stop in the street like or they
tickets still available
people who see it a bit of badges they
see me they were like what is this about
yeah no absolutely that's I starts just
awkward on the street especially like
this when you know people there you know
you're looking at smaller games that you
know parents are willing to bring their
children and something that they're
gonna be attracted to and then beyond
that once you're in there then you see
everything that's in there and it's
something for everyone he walked out of
there it was like left and right what's
that what are you guys going no
absolutely real quick girl shout out to
Pratt with the file a super chat how do
we get play Washington DC DC Metro is
home to Bethesda smaller devs and the
ESA so he's he's making his push Lorden
can we get a pay busy I'm glad he
brought that up because play craft and
even though we got started in New York
we are in multiple cities already and so
if you're in and around the Boston area
we do events all year around
same thing in San Francisco we just
started doing stuff in San Diego in
Seattle DC has been like at the front of
mind for a while
mm-hmm I'll spend just the fact that
play DC sounds so nice
but yeah there's a ton of smaller
Studios there's a ton of larger studios
like Bethesda that are nearby and so
this kind of thing is is scalable and
can go to any number of different
directions and I think that now that
play NYC is three years old and this was
the first year that fairness we broke
even to the money get to the back baby
now that we are at that point we are
like seriously considering where we're
gonna build this next and so DC's on on
the list there are some spots on the
west coast that are on the list going to
spaces that are not typically associated
with games like you see it's more
exciting than like doing another thing
in a place that has 70 and so that's
gonna be a factor as we're talking about
moving forward but again we started as a
meetup group and that meetup group was
started by one guy who wanted to like
bring together some folks that work in
games or like games and so I'll say - so
the listener out there that like you can
start your own version of play DC just
bringing five developers to a cafe and
have them show their games to each other
and that's where it all starts and so I
think eventually we'll get to 15 20
cities but it's not us in the meantime
you can start your own version of that
and reach out to us on Twitter at play
crafting we're happy to give you some
pointers along the way
awesome good lord this little brat with
this tremendous question we gotta get
you outta assume but uh last question we
ask every guest this is a big one you
know this is a big one so I need Lord
this top five video game or franchises
of all time ok I'm going to because
three of the top five are Zelda games a
franchise number one is Zelda and if I
had to say like three of the games at
the top like rotate and being number one
of all
I'm I'd have to I'm back to ocarina of
time as my number one voicing on my dad
do you approve yes I one of those other
two zoning scholars do not approve of
the of the second one which is Skyward
Sword listen listen you said it rotated
let you know what you started what was
the third I just want to know something
then what was it with our sword that
made you like the game I just I just
really want to know that one point I'd
love to know this - Skyward Sword is the
vision of a one-to-one playing with a
sword as link aim realized that vision
was realized and I was completely
obsessed with it and I'll say like just
to put the the the competition to rest
Skyward Sword has for the most of the
time that I've had like my ultimate
games list and my list of all the games
I've ever played every week store it has
been number one more than the others oh
I say that knowing how controversial
that pick is but I absolutely the whole
world was like built around swiping the
sword in the right direction and I kept
that it didn't work for some people it
worked
150 percent for me and I felt and like
the the creature design it was like I
was playing a Studio Ghibli movie it was
perfect
the most important ally and the fact you
have made my we've officially found the
two people on the internet that like
scholar Zelda Gabe it's a its ocarina of
time Skyward Sword and then it was Wind
Waker but breath of the wild sort is
like number three so you still need four
more alright so number two is journey
and that ever made me cried experienced
Zelda's journey number three would be
for the n64 WWF no mercy
he said no mercy yeah that was our after
a while those games became our reason
phone what's funny is you guys always be
hyping up this game but nutty you see
what's going on but no mercy it was a
perfect game oh no mercy with a RAM card
like for me honestly we got WCW versus
the world right and we had played the
earlier iterations of that engine on
PlayStation we had imported all those
games and versus the world was the first
time it all came together and on the n64
the fact that you had
the four players you can go back and
forth the frame rate was horrible but
it's so much fun and every single game
in that series following WCW NWO revenge
then you had Wrestlemania 2000 and then
no mercy and every single one improved
upon that formula and no mercy was the
pinnacle was here every wrestling game
after that got far too complicated like
it was the perfect simple system simple
it was simple but it was deep in
execution yeah if you you had this I
wish we had video of some of our matches
back then so much that I I memorize all
of the systems in it and I like I told
you about like playing games with my
bigger brother like when I was younger
mm-hm I would play with him so much on
that game I knew exactly how to beat him
at every matter you memorized your
opponent at or matter shout-out to
kissable he was like it was the Aki ins
you go to chatted lo it was my kicks off
say it's just simplistic goodness but it
was almost Paper Scissors rock cause you
had strike you had grab you know it was
just so well done it came out when the
greatest wrestler of all time was there
and that's rikishi fatu on the ps3
online by accident cuz my uh my roommate
at the time we were about to go out I
was playing that some dude dressed as a
Spartan like Powerball me like 50 times
and I just I I turn that off I'm done
best things about those games and we
don't talk about it enough is the spirit
system parameter it was it was
witchcraft because we had no idea how it
works but simulated to come back
assimilated to come back in way that no
modern game has ever done it
yet your opponent was down the second
they were down all you had to do was
keep hitting that top button works
that's the hole it was there was the
beauty of it right because rest is about
taunt getting the crowd involved and
that momentum swing you know said now I
will say this there was only one thing I
know we going old over like mom they had
under that was that was the best video
for Esther games it was like it was a
little unfair sub table solve yeah when
you fought it skybox who knows what I'm
talking about right now
well you fought against the rock when
you fought against the popular Restless
ready to go like they're really hard to
be I remember a match when I fought I
fought Cobb Otsu and he had Goldberg at
the time before this quits went down
literally started the match and pulled
the analog stick in two seconds at the
start of the match we got we got journey
we gone yeah I finished strong we got
two more alright so the next one would
be Batman Arkham City Wow yes three
all angles here yeah there's like
there's three in my head and I gotta
pick one of them so I'll pick I'll pick
one of them and then I'll tell you what
the other two where I go for I would
probably go with portal mm not too Dan
portal both or - oh they're both good
but portal one portal one was a
revelation
- it improved on in every way what
portal one was yeah something like when
I got that in The Orange Box I'm like
what is this game yeah yeah because they
threw it in and then when I had to make
a portal and I threw the Box through and
it felt awesome okay yeah before I give
the other two shout out to fastback og
from the nlg pockets with a $10 super
chat shout out to Lord dizzy my Texas so
our bro prayers your way keep running
and fighting to get to the next level
hashtag appreciate iron Lord salute
brother man thank you brother means a
lot to Luke the Lord dizzy as well so
you said portal but there was other -
there's two more fighting for that last
part was the other dude yeah one would
be the Last of Us and the other one will
be Bioshock yes Wow outstanding list
later though I have like every game ever
played and this is absolutely tremendous
bad no you got almost like you got a run
but all bad this is amazing man we
literally could talk that would hold you
hostage but there's so much but you go
ahead you can follow me on Twitter it's
just at Dan butch go so da nbut chk oh
all things that we're working on over at
play crafting including play and I see
the bid Awards the global game
jam our expose in New York San Francisco
Boston and as we're spreading everywhere
else it's just at play crafting on
Twitter and to see if there's an event
or a class or a course or a convention
coming up in a city near you go to play
crafting calm so salute I am lost Lord
an absolute pleasure to have you back
definitely we will do this again
hopefully we'll run into you if PAC sees
cuz no Lord's will be there and keep
doing it keep doing your job keep
fighting the good fight man we love what
you're doing with your tremendous
ascension man this was really a good
time on an honor to have you in the
realm of the Lord's way yes yes thank
you guys so much and I definitely want
to come back Wow to come back man you
got to come back so chat please say you
shoutouts to door Danny show will
continue but again Dan thank you so much
for hanging man we are gonna get there
make sure I go and follow them on
Twitter and make sure that if you're in
the New York City area that you get out
to play and why because NYC I'm telling
you you will have a great time bring the
kids bring the kids absolutely man so we
are going to move on last week's poll
results are in and the people have
spoken to the question with the latest
rumors regarding a PS 5 and PS 5 pro
skier launching simultaneously do you
think a dual console strategy is the
correct approach by Sony heading into
the next generation the winner of a
fairly close three way ILP poll at 49%
is the no it confuses the market keep
that same energy when Lockhart and
anaconda trapped what that is that tight
what are you what's going on I didn't
expect that the window dudes to be like
man you know we don't do the - yes I
expected it to win but not that tight I
mean cuz it's like I felt like you know
I just felt like PlayStation nation the
way the same way I feel about it is like
they don't need to do that even if they
do come in slightly underpowered if that
is the case I don't think it affects
them the way it would affect Xbox I they
better not come in here with
at second place that 31 percent was the
yes give PlayStation gamers options and
price one price and power group not in
what options now you want a closer 21%
was our petit Lords I don't care until
the real powerhouse that's which Pro is
announced group very surprised you see
very surprised I mean yeah I mean to me
I like I said for me I don't think
there's a reason for and I was all for
it on the Xbox side specifically for the
reasons that I mentioned I thought you
know Xbox that's a narrative they can't
afford to give back up so if it means
you know covering your your your rear
and having to skews out there and that's
what it is but I don't think PlayStation
needs to do that at all but we go get it
to the show so I wanted to break it up I
know our addict you've got the
multiplayer thing we won't touch that
but what I start with soft first um so
did you watch the state of play you want
to talk about just the impressions I did
afterwards yeah I just wish they'd to
play and then we'll get into the main
availa attic takeover with the beta was
kind of overall low-key apart from you
know apart from the what people were
waiting for which was the Last of Us and
hopefully getting a release date which
we did okay play was trash Prasad Last
of Us pretty much so we got let's see we
got a demo from medieval that came out
at that moment the medieval Kree and
it's looking better than it did before
because when we first offer to just have
medieval remake it looked pretty
horrible
[Music]
they announced they announced the game
is coming to PSV I don't even know what
it is yet PSV are and regular ps4 called
humanity that was the first game that
they show but all these people falling
through things and it was weird that is
but notice he didn't know the name you
just said an Alistar you know I even
know the name but I'm reading that right
now so I didn't remember the name I'll
tell you the next game from the creator
of Katamari Damacy
a wat um which has been out like I guess
this thing has been kind of finally
officially coming out but I coulda sworn
wadham came out years ago anyway so
that's coming we're getting LA noire for
VR which has been out again on oculus
[Laughter]
we're getting that for psvr
there's another game coming out called
arise which looks like three things that
the PS Plus lineup would just right
that's all come on a PS Plus was fire
yeah fire because finally which is yeah
the last was born get everybody into it
whatever anybody who hasn't figured you
know I actually felt something really
funny it was a about the multiplayer
thing but it said it had a picture of
what's-his-name from the three they said
that stupid statement on the 360 like we
got a we got a product for you it's it's
360 like what about the multiplayer
most games or Last of Us remastered and
mo be the show 19 which lets go people
this is something that should happen
every single time yes every single year
give us that years and we'll be the show
MPs Plus at the end of the season lepida
play that game is no longer viable let's
give it to let's not do it with is
viable let's go out there we need no
care about it and put it out there
what's going on in you talking about the
car looks like part of that console
ladies and gentlemen yes is the throat
baby ctrl-x to you that speaks to you
through the PlayStation controller
speaker I was so disgusted was the
aesthetic that like I didn't even know
it had features play with power right
it's typical Kojima thing I have to
admit like when I first played Metal
Gear Solid in the first one and you had
unplug the controller to beat Psycho
Mantis that was awesome you know let's
hope this has some better functionality
no you're involved after that of course
we got a release date for the Last of Us
part two it is
Earth's 2023 Lobos trailer was Bantam I
love the last of us mostly because of
the story I mean for me 20 dog games I
go come to them for the characters the
relationships between those characters
last of us was the first story that I
really enjoyed cuz uncharted I get I
love the character the relationships the
stories never overall whenever the
greatest to me but Last of Us was really
special The Last of Us just tells the
story good like they they can tell an
average story so good it makes it above
average because it makes it about the
characters in the release you're really
good at that and to me this story with
Ellie
it seems fantastic they are expanding
the world in a way where it's still
linear but you're gonna have a lot of
room laterally to move around the world
it's much more realized it seems like
combat it's much more vicious obviously
Ellie physically is not can't do what
Joel does right so she's gonna be a lot
more of a scrapper and it's gonna be
gruesome and she's got it to me they're
gonna nail that part of it so I'm
excited about that and so let's talk
about what attic is excited oh no no no
no no when Philip finished telling about
the highlights let's talk about how
graphically it was amazing looking the
world look realized and look like it
took all their energy and balled it up
into one giant coming coming up and gave
you one single player and half-baked the
rest of the stuff that you didn't get
and I want all that same energy because
Gears of War got everything because I
want the same energy let's go I don't I
don't care about the multiplayer but I
knew that before we get into that skip
was that call of duty trailer behind
this this mode that uh apparently was
this office of one-year exclusive
wouldn't your exclusivity within the
spec ops mode it's a mode within the
mode and that's what's exclusive for a
year for a Playstation and people were
up in an uproar because it's like it's a
year by the time that happens people
already but literally by the time other
consoles and I paper believe piece
gets it you look next call next Call of
Duty and yeah that's my touch on that
because you know like addict knows and
King knows welcome to our world of death
as destiny fades the suffering and the
foolishness that we had to deal with and
thank God that Bungie is no longer
associated with Activision because this
is the stuff I was talking about and
it's funny to see the uproar now because
we've been fighting this fight for the
longest you know saying again I get it
it's business you want to get your
exclusive cool but no other company or
other I've never seen any arrangement
where you think it's Maps and content
for like two months a month nice release
syllogism but turn literally hold
content hostage for a year until by the
time it comes out the irrelevant it's
irrelevant it like that is it's a to me
and then the other thing is like I said
remember they'd even did it even two
years addict number they did it to us
with arm taking King with Jade rabbit
then I didn't get it into destiny to
dropped so sad so again all I've seen
pretty much all the game wasn't relevant
like I get it you know is exactly what's
going on here by the time we get that
mode the game's gonna be another it's
but at the same time it's like what I
don't love you that few fans of the lead
you don't say they're less empathetic
right but again when it happens to your
game now you go feel away so yeah anyway
Lord addict this is me tell you got
something okay if my computer was
functioning I will turn on the camera
dog felt like it was a good idea to not
launch with the multiplayer and to be
let me actually pause this real quick
cuz I got it I gotta go alright so first
off there that there is an interview
right now as of right now the
multiplayer is not coming out with Last
of Us
there's actually interview with some of
the DES where they say this game doesn't
have a multiplayer now people obviously
gone to the attach because they've been
hiring for multiplayer but I know for a
fact that in this industry when you're
hiring for a new project they say it's
an existing game hold on hold on I hate
to stop this time but practice saying
some things about the previous topic
that I have to drive he said oh he said
that first of all as he said it's only
one mode as far as Call of Duty and then
they brought it back he said did not
have having the exclusive content on
dusty change the game with a phone we
had on the xbox version that's not the
point Brett the point is one no it
definitely did like you got to sit down
with the kids you cut it down with Bret
they definitely affected the gameplay ok
talking about 1/4 less experience at the
same price no but the landing artist you
ain't playing we're talking about like
these are exotics like these are so by
the time the Xbox version got it it was
as for as a shelve is right so J Jade
rabbit or borealis two years before I
get that is a problem that is excessive
that's all I'm saying look I get
business if you pay for it you pay for
it but at the end of the day that is the
only deal I've ever seen structure even
division any name any other
multi-platform game matpat suits it's
usually a month or something if people
have the marketing rights to have
something a whole years that is be using
what's gonna happen is this right when
it's when when the table switch and it
go switch when they switch I just want
the same energy that's all I'm saying
anyway two hours of shots is life with
our podcast brother two dollars of Jack
Cooke Naughty Dog so I give it back - I
gotta fight a sorry it's not the fact
that you know I feel like okay kids who
says something always agree he says I'm
more accepting what the time
exclusive than I am time content because
at least at the time exclusive you know
where you stand you ain't getting that
game unless you buy that platform but a
timed content means you're charging some
consumers a completely you should you're
charging them the same for a less of a
game yeah it's not time to the special
edition to $80 Edition it's time to if
you buy the base Edition on PlayStation
you will get that and that's it and you
won't get the same amount on Xbox that
that's what's not good oh we got a super
jet
$1.99 Super Shot some content was
knocked he was locked the year after
destiny - yeah you know um I don't agree
with none of those practices and when
you're paying full price for a product
that the other person is paying it's
like you go to the store and you get you
know you get a happy meal whatever the
happy meal is it's supposed to come with
everything right you paying full price
now if they charge you a dollar more did
you get the toy inside fine that person
paid for that they should get that but
if we're paying the same exact price I
deserve to get the same exact thing and
I don't think that is consumer friendly
but we also see why Activision is no
longer with Bungie at this point in time
and we see business practices have
actually taken a turn for the better and
the crazy thing is if you look at the
call of duty situation at Walt I don't
and well Infinity Ward is addressing it
because they've said well in lieu of the
reaction we've gotten because of the
spec ops mode we have to reassess our
microtransactions because that is
another Avenue apparently that error
they're they're expecting to be attacked
through so it's something that they're
cognizant of they know the reaction they
even put up I guess your gamer put up an
article talking about you know Infinity
Ward sort of pleading with the community
to stop you know attacking them I guess
you know there's been some colorful
language between people who are angry
about this so they realized that it's
not something that that it's gonna be
this popular and they realize they have
to do something to sort of
alleviate that someplace else so we'll
see right Charlotte Brava he says I lost
your Xbox version get a 1% discount
since ninety percent nineteen I'm
sending a game I'm not asking for a
discount all I'm saying is people need
to gamers need to be empathetic of the
platforms they don't have something for
the same price and again in this case
one year is excessive this is a month I
don't care if it's three months like if
you follow the patterns of the industry
that is the only thing that breaks
complete pattern and all I'm saying is
we have to be empathetic for the other
platforms because by the time they get
that content the game is irrelevant that
messed up I don't see how you don't
understand how that's not an issue but
anyway and you know what hey we deserve
a discount all right one year is
excessive and as a gamer people should
feel away that's all I'm saying that
that's ridiculous continue addict shout
out shout out to Victor Allis tan with
the $2 super chat and all the dog being
naughty naughty dog what they did is
they've come out they've said that
they're working on a completely
different experience they said that
quote unquote
it was more ambitious so that they
pretty much had to extend how long it
takes you know first off they take
forever to make this statement this it
was literally like almost an entire day
mm-hmm
if you want my honest opinion I don't
think that the I think that the job
listings cuz I know for a fact in this
industry when you hire for a brand new
project that has not been announced and
when you're go on LinkedIn you're go and
you're posting job applications you put
it as isn't a title that has already
been announced and then when they get
behind closed doors you make them sign
of NDA then and then you tell them yo
you're not working on last was to you
working on this new title but we
couldn't put this new titles title in
the in on LinkedIn because we obviously
announced I know for a fact that happens
right so we did see the postings that
they were they first what they did
announce that multiplayer was initially
going to be the game when we did see the
postings for jobs for people to work
from norther they're gonna be working on
the multi player way back so that I
think what's happening is I think
Naughty Dog is going to make a
free-to-play version of factions and
it's going to be filled with micro
transactions and I think they're gonna
try to go like a what's where I'm
looking for they're gonna go towards a
like a games of service kind of like
kind of like a would destiny doing now
where you have like a battle pass and
stuff because I do not see like if you
look at it from a standpoint like how
much more vicious can you possibly be
with factions it's not like it's those
complicated multiplayer in the world you
know if it turns so what are you doing
that means you need to extend it like
this in the over if that is true then
they're making their own version of like
an apex legends like it's going to be a
separate thing completely within that
world and it will be much more than
factions right and I think you could do
a lot with that like I've I've never
been I understand people's affinity for
it because it's different than a lot of
other multiplayer you're gonna find out
there but they have to make a product if
they're gonna spend this much money
right they have to make a product that
has real longevity and real legs and
it's in the conversation with other
games as a service in terms of money
making if not they're not gonna spend
the money on that anymore but they make
a project does complete how about that
part I'm at the same energy I'm looking
for energy here folks and these dudes
you won't tell me I was anticipating
even though I was never gonna touch the
multiplayer but I want it yeah alright I
paid for I want complete games all this
half a date stuff and these guys talking
all and it's the single-player
experience this is exactly where imagine
I imagine with you guys and you know I
hate to say this man but if Microsoft
would do some stuff like this it would
be bad if Gears woulda came out with no
multiplayer bushes bound gears and then
I told you I can't stand you know like
obviously I know kognito feels the same
way but maybe not necessarily the exact
same way but you know what I'm tired
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
what I'm tired of is this narrative
going around that you can have a
complete single-player and it's a
complete game but if you have a
multiplayer only gang beside a complete
game like this bad energy brother blows
my mind you know what another ner I'm
tired of people acting like Sony's the
only people that make good single-player
games that blows my mind to weave how
many games these this year has third
party that scored a 85 or above on
Metacritic but no adding by adding this
is this that's not only it this same
only Sony can get away with this crap
they this is only Sony can get away we
give you have games
integral to the game experience like
here's multiplayer explain people people
still play Last of Us multiplayer eSport
like it's not it is not as integral to
it when people think Oh alas the buzz I
don't think about Last of Us multiplayer
Jersey if I do not get a Jersey with my
purchase and I'm not part of a league in
a team you gonna tell me I can't get
multiplayer if I can't
but--look setting if you make it if you
I'm sorry if you make a product and you
have a good following if your game is
still being played online six years
later mm-hmm
then you need to make sure your
sequel has that same old ok shout out to
stooge is EXE he says gotta be an esport
what the f what I'm saying it has to be
financially viable for them right so it
doesn't have to be an eSport but they're
looking to make that kind of money and
if you think that's not what they're
looking to do and not gonna invest the
time and effort I think this is a
classic thing this is another notch that
I'm putting on Sony that they're getting
too cocky they're like you know what
launch this last of us because we know
the PlayStation 5 is coming out at the
end of next year launches before we
don't care if it's got no multiplayer oh
you need more time that's after the game
comes out you can do that we got to see
we toss out the brat with the file a
super shot is going to be a battle royal
mole based on factions releasing on PS 5
still it's disappointing that
multiplayer will now be there at launch
who got my boy and whitey who I will
after I dress properly it's not that
it's coming after launch it's not coming
it's gonna be completely different game
so we got a twenty dollar super chat
probably put your name on we go okay two
characters in one like apex legends
called so deal edges but I would die you
might be like oh like all broken clocks
this is one of the two times a day we're
adding this even when it gives you props
he kicks you right you know I'm Tipton
yeah there's such a good move slomo I
would delete your whole super chair oh
my lord
Zell I ain't even trying that last time
you have to excuse that be a guest then
whatever babe
that's all you saw $2 super chair they
can't even make a 4k 60 frames game
ain't nobody to make 4k but you know
that's just the thing that it's like
look like call a spade a spade
right sure you if you like this single
clay I will agree with you not a lot of
people talk about the multiplayer that's
true mm-hmm
but just because know what not everyone
and everyone's mom when they talk about
last was talked about the multiplayer
does not mean it doesn't have a fan base
if you're six years after a launch and
it's still full of servers that means
you have you as a company should I buy
and make sure them people are good or
you got people like BG having an OCO a
full meltdown on twitter over not having
the multiplayer and the people with him
I'm with him I support his rant but you
know I want to sleep feel like if you're
upset in this ain't no shot to BG you
shouldn't have buy the game the game
I have no damn choice attic series is
this is this is the problem right here
right they give you these half-baked
game and they telling you it's
completely cooked and it's not cooked
all the way through I'm sorry there's a
little purple in it you say it's a
little undercooked in the middle now I
will say this though I will say this if
this mode obviously they're working on
something to have something right if
this comes out they say the multiplayer
comes out around the time of the launch
of the PS 5 right and then a year then
that makes it even worse it makes it
even worse because I'm like why not just
hold off the launch of Last of Us till
the end of the year have it be your
bombastic you know fall game with the
launch of the players 5 have it be a
cross-platform game because you know
it's gonna be playable on both right a
version of it whatever why not hold if
this multiplayer comes out near the end
of the year perfectly I'm sorry we got
70 people in this chat you know
definitely appreciate room come on go
ahead hit that like button get that up
get those lights
man I can't help it I might need to put
that in Google Translation right now
shades on as long as we chat you know
what you are saying right this is the
problem multiplayer be Scarlett comes
out doesn't make sent wants on if you're
hitting to dislike you're in my boat I
don't care about multiplayer give me a
game I don't care about it I'm just
playing the devil's advocate
I'm cuz it is true if that if the
multiplayer comes out at the end of the
year what was the point okay I'm gonna
take my color shades off and read one
chair online will launch a first
single-player later the difference is is
you got def saying that this game
doesn't have a multiplayer is no
multiplayer coming for this game y'all
been selling soda bullets the devs came
let's read the statement cuz the devs
did come out and say they said look you
know the whole thing in reference to we
want to address the multi player they
say you know was the vision was beyond
and as the team drew in additional mode
that can be included with our norm
single player campaign wanted to support
both visions we made the difficult
choice the Last of Us part 2 will not
include an online mode however you will
eventually experience the fruits of our
teams online ambition but not as part of
the Last of Us part 2 so separate mojo
when and where it will be realized and
still to be determined but rest assured
where there are big fan as factions as
my community my question is the way they
worded that it seems like it's not part
of last - right baby that's not it I
lived a day literally verbatim said it's
every King you drop an exam ready what
day was this this day finesse they
showed you the finesse Oh check it out
we're gonna give you this right now
you're gonna pay for this right here
first right and later on might have
something that might have something
vaguely to do with something about
something they not telling you that you
won't pay for that - isn't that
impression with I love you think this is
gonna be a free to play actions you are
going to pay for this game in some photo
fashion this is the Sony finesse let me
tell you your wives slowly was agreeing
with King he said it's gonna be a
standalone game they gonna charge you
for if you just your case you gotta get
super check before you get this one
okay um shining Moon Kingdom seed listen
I got these shades on I can't see
anything right now
plus I have reading glasses yeah except
me it keeps it me a pair of the shape
I'll be part of PlayStation 5 with the
[Applause]
played a multiplayer listen this is a
separate game you're gonna pay for it in
some form of fashion they just realized
they said yo why are we giving them this
extra model for free don't people pay
for this and it must be so sweet they
they know they gonna finesse you so they
okay so we're gonna give them this they
gonna buy this they definitely go
they have no choice sure that the
release date show them a trailer
complete let's show them some some
gameplay the game let them get thirsty
no no don't forget that they're not
getting multiplayer for free it's not
for free you saw as a package is a game
is a package a co-op couch co-op so our
new thing is online right right so you
supposed to be playing over there I
don't agree with sovereign that if I
don't have a jersey that I can't you
know get the multiplayer because it's
part of some big elaborate uh League now
they're going to charge you for this
game when it comes on I just want to see
the same energy that they chew double
the price for a single play a game that
should have had the multiplayer included
Oh shout to Yohan's LVS find out a super
chat all kidding aside the last verse is
going to be a fantastic game Naughty Dog
just sucks at making multiplayer that's
not necessarily true I've never really
played a multiplayer game but like
people I respect in this community now
that love multiplayer loves to Minardi
dogs multiplayer necessarily they can't
make a multiplayer they chose not to our
podcast that somebody said that
multiplayer with the last of somebody
said the last was probably BG it they
said that's a less multiplayer they
still play it yes PG that's why I've got
to get it go literally go shout out the
lord because he had to me I almost crash
yo he's got one of the funniest videos
this is a passionate Last of Us
multiplayer fair yeah I had to salute
Obi's he was so busy no he was rotted
die but he made some fantastic points
and he's been on you don't say drachmas
headway he's making some just going to
bail his ego it was one of the best
videos and I respect here's the thing
you're like in the early stages we knew
this
game initially stated they had
multiplayer we know they had dabs one
point you know they've signed up for
there was a mold initially this time it
was presented to us that this game would
have then addict was the first to bring
to my attention shout to addict Lords he
gave me died net y'all he put it up it
was that days of play ps4 box remember
Matic and you show me you like yo it
says last of us to will not have one I
saw that off the actual event and then
it started cutting like articles started
coming and I and people was like well
maybe it's a misprint look when you make
a case you don't accidentally put on the
thing that it specifically said no boats
for everybody the exact work so nice
when my eyebrow was like alright yo
what's going on here and you know we got
then we get the bad news obviously
recently and I gotta be look I gotta be
keep it why honey I got standing on it
like at the end of day dude I got the
right to reserved to pull it yes but all
this single player was too ambitious
stuff that's why I saw where BG I feel
that's marking speak I feel that like if
that was the way you should have come
out from the very beginning and say look
or at an earlier period say look the
multi player is gonna be a separate day
but to wait right at the moment you will
allow your release date and Blake oh by
the way you get me they didn't even
announce it was brought to the attention
by idea yes this is where that's the
part where almost crashed I am a
wordsmith
yes he said that we gave you the jargon
misuses and he said you can't you can't
be slicker than a can of oil can you he
said that's the powwow almost crashed
we're over and I've had to watch it
again because it was one of the most
passionate I played as I'm looking
forward to this and you look at all
rappers on your neck okay there's a ten
dollar super chat from Pratt and if you
are confusing cockiness with confidence
and alright we'll get to that here in a
second breath 100 million ps4 is king
half-baked gang rule would be game of
the year continuing there I love how
okay so how are you gonna say contender
but you say confidence so if they don't
have enough confidence to know you don't
have enough confidence in them to no
that's not game of the year he's gotta
be a contender I'm gonna go we'll get
back to that in a minute
mm-hmm they will charge for that stand
alone or free with their anthem Tia
microtransaction look this is definitely
not confidence this is one of those
baton switches this is we're gonna tell
you what's gonna happen but we're gonna
switch it up at the last minute if it's
come up in its Brad why didn't they say
mmm listen the median outs of breath
listen I just again I don't like the
last-minute nature of it that's where
they sent home but they had an ample
enough time to realize during the
development cycle in my opinion right to
say look this is not gonna come out at
that time so here's the England for the
record I'm working I'm not some big
hardcore last much more than playing I'm
not even gonna be interested but it's
the prism it's the thing like here's why
I'm a saw like I'm just not a fan of
video games regressing on features that
they had already mmm like my thing is
regards how I feel me personally the
multiplayer it look at the first game
and there's a passionate community that
wants that feature so my thing is what
gamers are saying it again I'm not
coming at you direct sell but I'm just
saying I see a lot of game and say well
I don't care about more playing so so
what you should care because at the end
of the day that's a feature that was
part of the experience that's now be
taken away and I'm just gonna use this
example like you know would be a good
example is that's the equivalent of hey
we'll take it out forge again oh yes to
be taken out gambit or you know
regardless if I don't you guys taking
out hordes right no because everyone
doesn't play doesn't mean no one wants
to play right at the end of the day just
because you don't like it personally if
there's a group of gamers that still
enjoy this thing and it's a feat and
let's take come out and say yo
financially we can't sustain it right or
you know just oh just just get in front
of it I had ever time say look we're
just gonna have a dev time but don't
wait till you launch your release date
and then try to hit me
I feel that completely my thing is okay
my personal reasons I don't care about
it right and I know I'm sure that a lot
of people play last of us who don't care
about it they care about the single
player right fine that's that's not a
valid reason per se that's a subjective
reason right looking at it objectively
right like I said earlier we are at a
point in gaming where it when it comes
to multiplayer modes everyone and it's
unfortunate cuz you look at Naughty Dog
and you don't look at them as somebody
who try to cash in or something like
this right everything is about
monetization in some way shape or form
for it to be viable for it to be viable
which requires more work more time to
make it into something that they know it
can't be egregious cuz people gonna flip
out
right so to me this is what I'm saying
that that's what it is they're gonna
make it a separate thing because it's
gonna be a more detailed thing it's
gonna be a more in-depth thing and
they're looking for ways to charge for
stuff fine without you flipping out and
that's fine all I'm saying just be
transparent about what you're gonna do
then you won't get the reaction and
here's my thing and we gotta keep it
true y'all like listen let's do the
financials here we all know the
PlayStation 4 user base is 100 million
whatever it is right okay so to me this
feel like the double dip you know if
it's not ready then hold it back for ps5
right put you down what you gonna do
this smart business I'm not I'm not not
gonna hustle small business you bring it
out now even though multi players not
ready you get that honey million you get
that that that base that's the bigger
base right oh to go cop Last of Us now
then P it's v launch you got this little
faction mo you come packaged it up
remaster call to paint higher fidelity
grass bang-bang-bang
they did it they know he did it this is
the same formula at the end of the ps3
generation right last came out towards
the end and then when it's for debut we
got the remaster
with the high you know
this is a double-dip I gotta call it boy
I'm not mad at the huh sure I understand
but let's just be real about when you're
going the store you put your money on
the counter the finessing is happening
understand your part of the transaction
you have been fitness I just want you to
know you're going in Eyes Wide Shut
right I want you to open them I want you
to see it now now I want you can see the
finessing and when it come down and he
comes off a PlayStation file with the
move and you're gonna be like no don't
bite again you can get free next flights
nobody could place it last of us already
had crazy microtransactions nobody could
play
he said we said we accepted it it was
crazy it's been egregious busy sites
like he's about tired everybody open the
eyes up now let me I want to ask y'all
this I don't we reran we go up here's
the question I've seen it I would've
shout BGI we should add them on today
but this is perfect but listen you like
what I'm seeing - a chat now I gotta ask
the chat and I gotta ask the Lord's this
life because of this situation it's far
as Sony's first party because ice meat
line it's for the majority of their
first party it's generally single play
experience so people are saying a chat
like Twitter that like what's the
purpose of me having PS plus if all
again hey they not go ahead and bow that
but do you agree with that or do you
think that PS Plus is still we put
something with that do you feel like
Sony should rely exclusively on third
party multiplayer and not make any
multiplayer themselves that's a revert
from Microsoft stance I said I don't
care I get you you're under the I don't
know like I said people aren't even
person maybe they don't make great the
greatest multiplayer so they focus on
what their strong is that let me get
this that was to put chat from Pratt
because they wanted those pre-orders but
if they confident why do they care 100
million you're not gonna hold this game
back any
let's get it out get that front and the
back yeah remember okay when when the
switch launched with rest of the wild
right 2017 right and I said that it was
gonna be like a double launch cuz what
didn't the DLC come out right at the
holiday season when they were getting
finally getting more consoles in stores
hustle right like it's like you have
additional content that you're gonna
repackage and be like this is the game
of the year edition with you know and
then oh there go Christopher hi I was
waiting for you know he was gonna be
honest that no multiplayer is not game
breaking we know let's be real here we
know it was not in color Chris we know
we know that the single player is gonna
be good enough to validate the $60 price
tag that is not the issue
the it's not the issue of whether or not
this game is gonna be worth the money
without the multiplayer the issue is
should they have done this with the
multiplayer knowing that they had such a
big following knowing that they had so
many people looking forward to this like
you literally had a meltdown like they
beat you was only person go look at
people the community was split it's the
first time it was a PlayStation Civil
War shout to my boy Jayde though I was
just watching Twitter I'll just like
what I want to say this to all the
people as that's outraged right now I
want y'all to stand up I want you to go
I want you to remove your pre-orders for
the game and I won't wait until the
multiplayer comes out I want you to vote
with your dollar you have the same
energy with the freight upsetness put
your money where your mouth is I want
you to do it
see when I was telling y'all was stadium
and after that sort of stuff I took my
money off I said no sir you will not get
my dollars this is not gonna happen
and I want you to do the same acolyte
King you I want you to say what were
King do in a situation he will remove
his bucks and but listen I'm telling you
right now
I'm frauding I'm 40 because I'm with
y'all
I'm totally upset it doesn't have
multiplayer is it gonna stop me from
buying no way absolutely and at the end
of the day we kind of know that they
know that as well but they do it I will
say this no this is where I agree with
BG if he still is that when the
community does outcry in this Manor
Manor they were forced to make a
reactionary statement they were forced
to now get in front of it so this wasn't
like five or six people on right like it
exploded I believe it was musician right
there wasn't a petition that was um what
you call it yeah you know I want to go
ahead and get in front of that it is not
what's what is it what's word I'm
looking for
it's not being dramatic to make a
petition petitions are literally
everywhere
it's literally literally all petition is
is how many people are opposed or for
something like that's literally all it
is if you want to sign that petition go
sign that petition but what was funny is
Beatty on what but what he was like yeah
I sign that petition and they're like BG
it says in the first sentence by signing
this you agreed not to bite this game is
like they don't even know I will we had
to get it this is too much but we got
what more did we get out of here man I
don't like the fake it listen let's
shout out that was a good listen I love
Larry her right I really do everybody
else on that panel can go away ants in a
fig joke you see when Larry answers so
sarcastically to them like it was right
at the beginning he was like yes Thank
You Don Larry and shook his shoulders
there
where they were supposed to high-five
and the chick had her hand up for like
10 seconds and put it down way along
listen I'm so I'm so opposed to them put
a Larry with those boobs separate Larry
for them
that's one alright so you want a good
inside Xbox what I did like with inside
you're a real game place cuz it's that
looks kind of weird it looks kind of
spooky I'm honest I'm being honest I do
not like the fake jokes it's porn G is
corny and it's not necessary but they
did have a lot of stuff dizzy I know
that you're happy where Atlas um because
that looks like the national the natural
evolution of that crap game art that she
was trying to get me to play but honey
so I had to laugh how they had to come
out and say hey we know that sea of
thieves exists yeah beat that up beat
that I just realized what can you see
look to me it's just like they just
focus too much on the panel say
PlayStation did copy direct trailer
trailer trailer trailer trailer then if
you want to have a deaf come out really
briefly talk about it looks bad more
fine but the trailer like we don't have
to keep seeing y'all making jokes like
that is do what Bungie does Bungie has a
good amount of game playing talking to
get it quick they get all that out the
door then they move the hell listen it's
not for us to know that but it's just
one of those things that it couldn't
literally improve we're happy exist but
the current formula I just fix it it's
not an fix is like the same regurgitated
crap and y'all keep thinking we want
personalities yeah you don't have
personalities those are false
personality and whoever's writing these
jokes from Victor he says inside Xbox
needs to be structured like a podcast of
games and interviews I don't agree with
that
I feel like inside Xbox needs to be a
show floor that just goes from game to
game and you know that they could have a
break but they don't have to be exactly
like the rack they can show like half of
first off you can cut it dramatically
only show that interviews that count the
ones that people careful am I still the
only one that doesn't understand what
this is what this events made for super
Joe then you're crazy not to wrap with
the five dollar super chat Major Nelson
needs to be the marketing insurance
insurer and I sure don't think he
resonates with game
bill about the cream on something well
you know what you know they need to take
in control of that whole thing that dude
that host the the PC gaming show I love
him like if they need some of charisma
that actually could resonate with gamers
and I as much as Major Nelson school hmm
he's just not it and this is being real
all the Queen's were these stuff didn't
come from major right except when he did
the crazy I do what he did the crazy
yeah but hey listen look this is what
I'm trying to say didn't let him lose
somebody wrote that crap listen he's
standing on the side he's trying to be
straight-laced he's trying to get you to
information and knees duals these jokers
honestly he touched his shoulders
discussed in Larry's face I was
disgusted with you Larry I'm reading
order Chris yeah with the two pounds
super jet clean jokes is the best part
of it like listen this yeah I'm not
gonna say you're onto something I'm not
onto that what what salute for the super
chair but to me only people who should
be getting screen time is when Phil
comes on or when you know giveaways give
our boy that chance to shine there don't
let him say his cringe-worthy stuff let
him give the stuff away and it's like
back to the rail and it goes back to the
next day just and then afterward they
say something else I just feel like if
it was just that the length of the show
that would be one thing but there's more
of all things wrong with inside Xbox
it's not just a link to the show right
it's the cringe-worthy it feels like
they're what's one I'm looking for
they're not on the same page like a
frame it's like the chick was trying to
high-five that dude it completely missed
it I'm just like shadow Brad with the
file item J Xbox deeds attics beard to
host much love for you I don't know if I
could do that because my beard is very
picky all that kind of thing you just
get to the point where this was my whole
point with the inside Xbox inside Xbox
showed you all the games that was coming
up forward the cringe-worthy stuff can
go to the left
I like that let's being shown I like a
couple of the games there was me Sean
I'm not as detailed as solver because
I'm going off the top of my memory mob
this thing with X cloud the fact that he
talked about X I'm going to go sign up
right now to get that done that had the
same effect to me and stay to play when
they told you about the Last of Us what
means what we have to understand this
first they put both of them on ok and we
as gamers won that day everybody won you
got the information on the Last of Us
and the release date of the coming out
and Xbox game has got X cloud and you
can go sign up for it and it gave you
more you talked about the games the
streaming from the console to device
they talked about a cloud streaming so
if it was unclear about the messaging
with X cloud they clarified it they may
need you understand this is what this
does this what this does and this is
what this is about because we go to
opposite way um yeah man that that was
the highlight for me you know saying
because you guys carry on you got to the
point hey boom it's gonna be us Korea UK
and I'm saying for right now and I'm
saying with the early joint then they
talked about um I wanna shout out hot if
he's still in shadow a little gave him
down now he's got all the information
please check that out the games dough
king
halo 5 yes years yeah instinct and I
think these also enlist but the fact
that all right we already touched a low
five
yes fourth first-person game sixty
frames per second that's a lot of
confidence to be showing that off yeah
yeah you got gears new brand new game
okay cool but to me the underrated thing
is killer instinct because let's be real
so I'm gonna learn fighters historically
don't showcase well or no streaming
train so if they're putting up off
you've got confidence in yours at least
imagine confident like Naughty Dog okay
but like to me that lineup from from a
latency perspective yes it's really
gangster um only thing I was gonna say
his arm yeah then the obviously they
talked about you know the requirements
and then they talked about like I said
you got the cloud streaming what was
interesting they said the caocao
streaming will allow all your games that
you or at least that's how they put it
they said the cloud streaming is limited
to what they have up there I guess if
you know the one that's available if
that's gonna be a game pass thing but
what's very interesting is the console
streaming I want to shut it out because
I'm actually in the alpha for that you
gotta have 10 up 10 megabyte upload at
least Bluetooth controller leave your
Xbox on instant on and that to me is a
big deal because that could be the way
they get around no more how we talked
about project analyst right and we say
you're me a could be awesome some foul
stuff and say yo we like an odd games to
stream out on now from y'all but if they
do console streaming which is it's in a
sense what remote play used to do but a
better version remember remote play you
use your Vita and you log into your
console but that was do the internet
you're avoiding the internet you're
going as your server route and it's a
better it's a better way of myself doing
it but I think this could be what you
think so they can get around will get
around illegal stuff with that
absolutely absolutely I think that that
is when when he announced that I
remember when Bill told us about that
with the console stuff wait a minute
okay
so now all of a sudden you eliminate for
certain people right who don't
necessarily need to have that server
hundreds of miles away
all of a sudden now you're creating
another network of interconnected
consoles and it's something that if you
when you think about it makes perfect
sense and we never thought about it we
we just thinking about 5g and all of the
different blades in the different
servers servers that have around the
country around the world this just
expands that exponentially we remain oh
and again if within the home as well
when you're creating an environment
within the home wait now you can access
them anywhere and you can literally do
the roleplay sitting on the throne
whatever you know we try to do with the
Wii U and the Vita and all that stuff
because you gotta remember to Asher's
reaches big but there are some pockets
that as you're right it's not at so if
those guys are like damn I don't my
service don't have that or whatever the
requirements is and they got a strong
connection in the crib right they just
going from their device to the crib good
job
talk about the zones that the beta is
going to be launched now was an
eye-opener within itself that's a big
deal which means they are really gearing
up and I thought that to me was a strong
like king say like and I was very strong
announced my question right the fact
that they're launching in that region
and they're trying to be the first in
that region they're trying to lock down
that area wasn't we talking about
getting to your base and installing your
base and I said before when everybody
said you feel need to stay out of these
areas where they're not strong in and
he's been when they when they purchase
land over this place and put a company
over there and they put a pillow over
there and I say they need to get out of
there and I said no he needs to hunker
down he needs to make his weakness of
strength and the fact that they said
South Korea they're launching the beta
of X cloud they chose this strategically
application you really have to think
cell phones is their main play state
like play area
right this is what they used to play in
game while they are working and they're
coming and moving once this cloud is
here
okay best I'll owe you big he said Xbox
out here stuttering like show you
exactly what you're saying but the level
of importance of this X cloud and I want
you to come back later after you get X
cloud in your hands and I want your
knees in that box you're gonna say I
can't believe this is not butter and
you're gonna throw your knees in the Box
you bleep you're gonna smile the same
way that you put your money up for the
last but no multiplayer you're gonna
give me your knees when you get that X
cloud blade that's right sir he says how
clean is amazing I do agree because it's
like again we're forgetting about the
major part which is partnerships with
ISP the ISP say yo t-mobile's ah yo it X
clouds one of the best to work with us
you don't like so you know there's gonna
be with these level of partnerships
either some type of deals may be some
type of tier structure they're working
this is the thing we were worried that
stadia how're they gonna get past data
caps are they gonna do all this earth
right Microsoft has a plan it seems I'm
not hearing any of this with stadia and
that to me is the separate it what
you're saying so no you're right the
ISPs I you know we for the longest time
if there's anything that we there was
sort of detracting us from the whole
idea of the streaming was what's gonna
happen with these data caps even the
people like us that don't have those
caps what how are those the prices on
our internet connections gonna go up and
I think you know the company's all
involved whether it be Google will be
microphone Microsoft or whoever they're
I mean that's something that they knew
they had to address from the very
beginning to ease the transition I'm not
saying in a couple of years it won't be
considerably more expensive mm-hmm oh
you're sorry you're right how about
those iPhone use well what you need to
do i phone users because I don't have an
iPhone what you need to do is toss it in
the bushes get that
coming past enough excellent you won't
have to go out and go get a second phone
we got a phone phone for you they have
them shown with their partnership today
they will work with Apple X cloud the
tools that they use they will be working
with it just apples a little tough for
the crack because of the ecosystem in
whatever but you're an addict what do
you think man about the ash cloud
announcer as well as just inside Xbox in
general it's cool I can play destiny if
they're poor I'm good all right cool
here's the other thing we forget about
the ISP is that remember if your console
streaming you also if you got a good
Wi-Fi where you act that alleviates you
having to do with the data stuff right
yeah yeah this is good options man look
options options man football is getting
close so we're gonna wrap unless anybody
got anything else on inside Xbox Google
just can't YouTube right
can't get you how the heck are they
gonna get stadia right king is right
actually the bushes close platform yeah
you know what you know like it's funny
that every stadia connect you have
buffering problems like that's that's
killing Google Hangouts on air and now
doing this other stuff they had to die
so stadia clip just not feeling what
they did to my smaller content crannies
that was file because people use that
service we use that service a lot of
podcasts and just the main issue I have
with Google and I'm gonna keep it
is that they almost feel remember some
Kingsolver know about this number when
you watched expected gadget raggedy day
and there was that hain you just see the
hand and the boss no don't help cutting
and petting the cat there's no one to
contact they're just they don't have no
direct number if something goes wrong
with YouTube you you just gotta wait
with automated stuff like it's just too
much exactly huh state is behind I like
my companies I want to be able to get I
felt like thing cuz now I don't know if
you know this but if you call Microsoft
support for Xbox they tell you to give
you a number to call back like can you
talk by someone you speak to a person no
eventually they call you just that
they're getting inundated with calls and
then they'll call you speak to a person
like there is no what I'm about to do to
a person that's what I'm saying is like
the overall customer service seems to be
changing in general I'm not condoning
with Google does like Google Google is
one of those people like you have to
make your complaint to like a paper
airplane and throw and hope someone gets
it like bro I never got answers to
simple problems I mean we add just
figure out on our own
Oh like literally I went to their forums
I did everything automated that they
wanted me to do and I never got a
response you know what you did you got a
like but yeah they sort of like when you
figured it out there was a he did it
strong so we'll see how that goes man
console streaming and or whatever so new
il people let's get it with the recent
announcement by naughty dog that last of
us to will not launch
initially launched when multiplayer and
instead a potential separate factions
mode at a later date do you agree with
the decision reason given by the
developer the choices are a yes The Last
of Us single-player should be made
priority and not worry about a tacked on
multiplayer mode be no lack of trying
pairen see and just an excuse to
monetize and ship a game with less
features see I don't care so da got no
boats our plan anyway about to cancel PS
Plus though is the question don't like
it should be like a like a boat B and
E's should take picture with this just
this one that is the question those
please doctor boat when it goes up on
ILP Twitter we had to salute again Lord
and Butch Co earlier for coming to the
realm of play crafting the CEO the boss
doing this thing man tremendous gaming
stories again if you missed it you came
late please catch the first hour when it
goes back up on ILP YouTube and yeah man
let's get these out Jones going Lloyd
attic what do you have going on sir
so I unfortunately have nothing going on
besides they went Tuesday comes around
don't expect me
okay I'll probably be tweeting cuz I'm
still on my my strong arm stuff on
Twitter I've been real real bad here
lately I need to straighten that up but
you know defalcation about to Lord act I
owe P I catch my youtube gaming addict
unfortunately I won't be posting
anything to I get this PC thing figured
out uh you know I don't know if this has
been announced but kits moose having
another challenge it's the blood war - I
don't know if he's going to announce
that but you know I also you just put me
on Twitter and I owe P and B X sovereign
on PSN Xbox Live I'm gonna try to play a
little bit of Gears today cuz I gotta
take a little while ago that I gotta
come into work so folded my Sunday it is
what it is nope you gonna be a remote
place
no Lord King absolutely around with five
people five but you got go long sir
oh man listen I got a statue coming in
from eBay I got three walk out my
eyeballs on then get listen I'm gonna
start up that probably cost more in my
car a lot of people like it I really
don't like it that much people liked it
I don't really like them anyway I'm
trying to do the spider-man universe
thing if you didn't see the combat talk
that I put a where else Prince jr. Shawn
Porter I'm gonna do a results because
they actually lit up the night they did
what they were supposed to do to two
guys to come you this is what you spend
your money on if you if you paid for
yesterday you got the multiplayer with
it and definitely but I want you to go
to Lords of gaming down there where all
that information is up there you can see
all that stuff yes in all our glory you
can see a lord Cognito up there with the
last word with iran's listen this week
destiny is about to get on and these
dudes have been on the forefront i
haven't been putting them on a back
burner because they've been throwing out
too much spoilers my way i really like
watching it but i can't watch it because
these guys have too much knowledge
notification ganging up support man
support lords gaming as well lord kyle
have stuff up but i wanted to give a
couple of shoutouts for the loggernet
team obviously dizzy our brother laughs
man I'm holding it down for us good to
see you in there live and energetic as
you know
self that was dope but um yeah man we
got um you know a lot of stuff up there
you already know like what King said the
opinion pieces
he's got Kayne West up there Ike's got
reviews going up there
we got game walkthroughs I want to shout
out the team you got some tremendous
additions I want to shout out my boy
Lord on 30 1737 his debut Lord you
Eugene he's got a Shenmue 3 hands yeah
fresh off the Tokyo Game Show welcome to
the team man it's a tremendous article
again regardless of what is really cool
should check it out and also we got Lord
josh reading aka Lord frost holding us
down in Disney's absence tremendous our
shadow key primer series so no spoilers
just if you want to know what everyone
in destiny is doing all the races all
it's really cool he does it every week
please check that out we got Lord Hector
the Macho Man my man he's got a
tremendous zelda review up there Link's
Awakening please check that out and of
course Lord mighty early knowing Lord
hide the tech gurus always giving us to
tech information Louis now then with the
division 2 and Lord MJ of course with
those deals if you want to sell gets you
know tell you what's going on out there
so please man support us Lords of gaming
dinette we appreciate the articles and
all that good stuff so for your country
con this week o Comic Con this week yes
I think I'm gonna be out there one a
week dragons TV the light following
subscribe go over there is Network he's
gonna definitely have information and
stuff up there to be gonna be a chat yo
also stream team roundtable distinct
team Monday's 9 p.m. go check them out
again King got the Batman Kos you
already see what time is added you got
the Borland 3 review right that's up
yeah that's you know please Lord gave me
down there please support man we really
appreciate it everybody let's get this
football Sunday it's popping we about to
go anybody got anything else no
everybody's your Sunday we push